Anahí delgados colombiana Perú ha vivido
la mayoría de sus 68 años en Venezuela
[Música]
desde hace siete años tras el cierre de
la frontera entre ambos países saca
provecho de la crisis para sobrevivir en
San Antonio vengo a comprar las
colchitas aquí porque tengo una
bodeguita tengo una bodega vendo vendo
esto
arrocito harina esto
galletitas chucherías chucherías el
gobierno venezolano de Nicolás maduro y
el colombiano de Gustavo Petro también
de izquierda acordaron retomar una
política de puertas abiertas Y aunque
por ahora la reapertura se limita al
paso de carga y de vuelos en cientos de
locales comerciales como este se
encendió una luz de esperanza lo que
queremos es que vuelva toda la
normalidad pues buena venta donde se
haya fluido de gente ya que pues eso
nadie en la cuarta parte de lo que era
la antes antes habían puestos de
vendedores ambulantes en todo esto
camiones con insumos médicos y productos
de aseo fueron los primeros en cruzar la
frontera en un acto simbólico el 26 de
septiembre
Kevin María Sandra Guzmán administra una
de las agencias aduaneras que logró
gestionar el primer envío a Venezuela
tras la reapertura se exportaron cartón
corrugado
dulce confitería vasos desechables se
desportó papel higiénico para el 2015 en
Cúcuta existían 68 empresas aduaneras
Ahora solo quedan cinco yo creo que ya
los ojos están derretidos De tanto
llorar de la alegría de la emoción de
saber que que podemos volver a arrancar
siendo legales y competitivos en esta
región
un nuevo comienzo cargado de retos entre
ellos convencer de legalizarse a los
comerciantes que usan diariamente los
más de 170 caminos ilegales conocidos
Como trochas que se han multiplicado
desde que comenzó la crisis diplomática